the sexual harassment scandal sweeping
the country is landed in the United
States Capitol congresswoman Jackie
Speier revealed yesterday that she knows
of two current members of Congress who
have sexually harassed staff members she
did not name either lawmaker around 15
million dollars in taxpayer money has
been paid out for harassment and
discrimination settlements over about
two decades with no transparency Jane
Crawford is on Capitol Hill with what's
being done about this Jan good morning
well good morning so lawmakers say it's
time to change the culture here on
Capitol Hill and do more to combat
sexual harassment in their own workplace
and yesterday those female members said
during a house hearing there are sitting
members of Congress who've been involved
in sexual misconduct there are two
members of Congress Republican and
Democrat right now who serve who have
engaged in sexual harassment California
Democrat Jackie Speier said
non-disclosure agreements prevented her
from naming names but she recounted
horror stories from ambitious women and
men who made it to Capitol Hill only to
be harassed having their private parts
grabbed on the House floor 1500 former
congressional staffers used this
petition to urge a change to us known as
a dispute resolution process which they
say may actually discourage victims from
reporting issues if a member of Congress
settles a claim as the harasser or is
found liable as a racer it is my belief
that the members should be personally
liable or required to repay the Treasury
for such damages but that hasn't been
the case according to the office of
compliance 15 million dollars in
taxpayer money has been paid to settle
harassment and discrimination claims the
chief of staff held my face kissed me
last month the California Democrat
described a rush of humiliation and
anger after being sexually assaulted
while she was a staffer on the hill
Virginia Republican Barbara Comstock
says a current member of Congress
crossed the line when a female staffer
brought documents to his home a young
woman went there and
was greeted with a member in a towel he
decided to expose himself after the
hearing speaker Paul Ryan moved to
require every House member and employee
to complete anti harassment and
anti-discrimination training because
harassment in any form has no place in
this institution now the Senate is
seeking its own reforms as well last
week senators pass a bipartisan
resolution making sexual harassment
training mandatory Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell said there could be more
actions ahead beyond us or some stunning
and disturbing revelations Jan thank you